welcome back to minecraft part 4
gaming week i was mining my house okay i
was building
this thing and i'm placing a stairs
and i see this guy who is that
what the frick are you go away
hello get off my property i have a gun
maybe he's a friend i don't want to be
racist
hello he killed the fish
hello hello i'm talking to you
oh jeez you're creepy oh god
minecraft isn't scary felix okay
dude we can be friends hey you want
melon
do you like this oh look at this he like
it
what are you doing with that block hey
hey put that block down
put that block that god damn it put it
down
put it down put it down put it down
where are you going oh god there's
enemies everywhere i have to kill them
all right do i kill enderman
he just farted
i'm sorry the melon hey melon
take it oh jesus
what the [ __ ] dude that was so scary
you better not steal my stuff dude
we're cool it's all good it's like
nothing happened
all right you just all right i'll stick
to what i'm doing you stick to what
you're doing
and no more melon from now on
the audacity of some people okay
so basically i built this indoor pool
it's pretty sweet it lit up at dark
and uh i'm like building the house just
making it nice
making it cool it's gonna like you know
be a thing
it's gonna i'm gonna live here actually
there's one thing i've been wanting to
do
because when you when i started playing
minecraft the
the bed was automatically red that's how
i remember
minecraft but now they have die and
stuff so i think if i do
this and this wow
it's a red bed now i feel at home
now i can sleep at night there it is
that's what i remember
oh that takes me back you wake up to
burning zombies that's what i like
that's what i like to see
i haven't finished this because i want
to fish
uh so we i want to have i want to have
actual fishes in my house
i want like the stars and this night and
everything to be epic no
i only have one string god damn it what
drops
strings so spiders drop strings i'm
sorry mr spy there
you have to die yes haha
oh also by the way oh yeah don't jump on
the crotch everyone lost their mind last
episode
i am learning as i'm going okay
no i'm not a minecraft veteran yet we're
going for the ender dragon snagging
uh what was i doing i already forgot yes
a fishing rod that's what we're doing
i know how to make it in by hand but
just so you guys
learn i'm making a fishing rod then of
course we need a boat right a boat
boat time boat time
sorry jurgen you can't come with me why
is the grass not growing
all right doesn't matter it's boat time
damn i'm fast oh yeah
oh yeah that's what i'm talking dude
that's a fish right there there's a fish
right there here we go bros here we go
come on come on grab it come on grab it
come on you want it do i need a bait on
the fish
don't laugh at me jurgen i'm trying here
do i need a bait for it i probably need
a bait for it
could i actually just capture him with
my bucket this is how we fish in sweden
with buckets
come here come here come here come here
come here come here come here
oh oh i got a bucket of my face
fishing haters said it wasn't possible
but i got a bucket of fish now you go in
there
oh my god i got a bucket of get a
[ __ ] butt we gotta get him a friend
we gotta get him a friend bros
technically you're supposed to row a
boat backwards
so this game isn't that historically
accurate after all
okay all right we're going scuba diving
can you make scuba diving equipment in
this
what the hell just happened got him
got him god it's scary down there
no i'm not scared of everything in
minecraft okay you know what let's just
make a bunch of buckets i don't have
time for this
it's bucket making time smash like if
you're excited for bucket making time
that's what i thought that's what i
thought all right we're making but
thought all right we're making buckets
i got a bucket full of bucket full of
sunshine
[Music]
jesus christ what is happening
oh you can drown in minecraft that's so
unrealistic
come here god damn why can't the fishes
breathe underwater then huh
explain that liberals let's try and find
more exotic fishes
you are oh god everything is scary in
this game come back here
oh god damn they're too fast squeezies
come on
all right you're too ugly you have to
die i'm sorry
those are the minecraft rules don't look
at me i don't make it up you're ugly you
die
darlo you're coming with me in the
bucket
right now i don't come in the bucket
all right in the boat then fine no
i want my turtle in my house can we
drown the people
oh kitty you're going in the bucket get
it you're going in the bucket
you have no saying kitty you're going in
the bucket you're going in the bucket
come here you snake god damn it
so disrespectful what's happening hello
what's he doing dude you got so much
bread bro
you don't mind do you cool i'll sleep in
his house
have you been looking at me the whole
night
oh sorry i thought it was my house
what i can make dyed pants what
leather okay six leather i'll be right
back
cartography table what
all right well this pool idea is very
underwhelming
why are they all there is it the draft
in the water
all right it's cow murdering time peter
i have to do it i have to get emerald i
have to get dyed pants
all right you're gonna die you didn't
even drop
leather you're useless they're escaping
they're escaping they're escaping the
camp
no they're all escaping what the god
damn it you're
you're dead you're dead you're just dead
that's what happened no one escapes my
camp
all right one gets to live because he's
good
you escape you died that's the rules
where that
oh my face you're all there you suck
dude all right well now we can get epic
pants at least
now we can get the gucci pants hey come
on did i tell you to stop
you the gucci pants guy there you are
six i need six are you crazy
oh my god dude let's let's bounce here
again these people are trying to swindle
us
all right well this works out because i
actually wanted to just ride out and
murder people
i haven't really explored the area
although oh wait
actually i forgot i want to make a
compass can you make a compass
i remember making a compass even back in
my day because i don't want to get lost
i don't want to lose my epic house boom
boom boom
and then in the middle there's my
compass all right we're going out on
adventure
[Music]
oh it tells you where the house is
oh that's so nice stop stop resisting
stop persisting we got six okay no more
killing
we only reap what we sow that is not how
that expression works
okay well i feel a lot more confident
just riding off
seeing what we're gonna find you know
what i'm saying like who knows what
we're gonna find
like a little hole that's pretty cool
actually i do need
coal hold on hold up one sec
here again
again
where's here again you're again
it's getting dark here again
you're again he must be here somewhere
oh god hello have you seen jargon
oh god they won't help me i looked away
one second and then he was gone
have you seen jargon oh my god
he must have fallen down the hole or
something he must be so scared
god oh no
i was hoping maybe he ran back home
oh where the hell were you
you were so scared again oh
i'm so happy oh i'll never leave you
again here again
oh jesus almost fell down there
my god it's dangerous
this game whoa what a mountain
well what is that
is that a shipwreck what is that
all right you're gonna stay here
gonna make sure it's safe
what kind of wood is this
uh is that a treasure chest
what that's glowing
oh my god minecraft
oh my craft
paper hey you're again
god damn it why does he keep like stay
oh god not this again i left him here
oh i hear him you snake where are you is
there a way to get a whistle to get your
horse to
you're again oh my god i look so
pimp i have less armor but i look cool
so it's okay
what if i hear him but not see him
what what the hell is this
have you kidnapped jargon
hey what the hell are you
you trying to kill me i kill you
is that a crossbow you shoot way too
slow bro
cool it's getting dark again and jurgen
is nowhere to be found hey look more
anime flowers i love them
i hear them here they are not here
explain that
oh my god what the hell are you wearing
what is this they must have captured
jurgen klopp
give him back to me
jurgen are you in here you're again
i hear you
i hear you he's in the trees or some
[ __ ]
oh my god
why do i feel like i'm going crazy where
this yard again the thing is i hear
you the ghost of jurgen is haunting me i
swear to god
he was my only friend
now i can't find him
i looked away two seconds
and then he was just gone
just like that
[Music]
where oh my god where were
you keep disappearing
oh all right we have him back
i looked all night literally all night
i don't know what you were doing and i'm
not even gonna ask
i'm going back home jurgen
what the hell is that is that a donkey
you want to come with me donkey
you want some wheat
are you kidding me are you kidding me
yeah again